among the papers Myra Hindley kept with
her in her dying days was a draft of her
unpublished memoirs correspondence in it
she blames the infamous Moors Murders on
her lover Ian Brady she wrote I was
completely besotted with him his beliefs
eventually rubbed off on me
and caused me to accept and do things no
one should ever do Hindley and Brady
were jailed for life in 1966 for killing
three children then they later confessed
to two more murders they died behind
bars the papers chart how the couple's
relationship turned bitter in a letter
to his solicitors which he copied to the
Home Secretary
Brady wrote ahead of one of Hindley's
bids to be released we were a unified
force she regarded periodic homicides as
rituals of reciprocal innovation
marriage ceremonies theoretically
binding us ever closer
Brady compared Hindley with the Roman
Empress Messalina legend describes
Messalina as a murderer a symbol of
vanity and immorality Hindley responded
in a letter to her own solicitor
accusing Brady of terrible sex abuse
before and during their crimes
she wrote he stripped me gagged me and
beat me with a cane raped me the
relationship powers have completely
disintegrated hate is a strong word but
it's probably appropriate in in this
instance she is very quick to complain
she's very quick to write letters she's
very quick to cut off relationships if
they're not going in a way that suits
her and these documents kind of add
weight to that character description of
someone it was absolutely utterly not a
Wallflower Hindley and Brady's young
victims were buried on Saddleworth Moor
near Manchester both killers were taken
there to help locate the graves the body
of victim Keith Bennett has never been
found in letters to Hindley his brother
Alan
to reveal Keith's burial site so
desperate was he he showed concern for
Hindley's health and offered to help her
mother
the Hindley papers are now exhibited at
the Crime through time Museum the latest
addition to an area dedicated to
Britain's most notorious child murders
they also include Hindley's first
attempt at an autobiography
33 years ago she wrote about confusion
over her birthday while she a Wednesday
child full of woe or a Tuesday child
full of grace I hope she wrote I'm at
least a little of both
that will be disputed by the families of
the victims of Britain's most notorious
child killer
Martin Brant Sky News Gloucestershire